leurs batteries a eu son plein et
promettent de ne rien lâcher les maires
de banlieues s'attaque à la mairie de
paris réunie au sein d'un collectif ils
vont saisir la justice pour s'opposer à
la résiliation du contrat autolib' avec
le groupe bolloré pourrait leur porte
voix le maire du chéné la décision
validée par les élus du syndicat mixte
s'est faite sans véritable concertation
pas de formation pas de communication
pas de participation en huit clos et
puis pas de document avant tout en
précipitations et comme par hasard en
plein été donc je rassure nos
administrés nous sommes là pour défendre
leurs intérêts bien évidemment financier
nous serons là cet été plusieurs recours
seront déposés devant le tribunal
administratif l'objectif des élus
empêcher l'arrêt du service le 31
juillet prochain
principal visé par ces recours la maire
de paris et la présidente du syndicat
autolib
tout ceci est un fiasco
non pas du syndicat mais de
l'actionnaire majoritaire de la ville de
paris car il ya également ce problème de
gouvernance
est-ce que c'est madame hidalgo qui
préside le syndicat
ou est ce que c'est la présidente
actuelle la fin du contrat avec le
groupe bolloré a été décidée après les
annonces autour de la dette d'autolib
estimé à près de 300 millions d'euros en
psa et renault pourrait prendre la suite
du marché de l'autopartage franciliens
fin mai plus de cent cinquante mille
personnes étaient abonnées aux blue car